[Music]
you know it's funny because JJ Abrams
was on the program promoting Star Trek
into darkness and he showed a clip of
you that had been deleted from the movie
in the shower scene life I've appeared
on your show and like you on your show
I've got a shower scene so it's kind of
a weird thing that was I did one on
someone else to show yeah I know it's ok
Chelsea Handler's no that's fine in
common I will never get naked on my show
it's the birthday we want more viewers
not fewer but I was curious
we were you okay with JJ's showing that
that edited scene got on the women were
very excited went kind of crazy no III
you know I trained for a good few months
to try and look a bit bigger than I am
and and when I said man we're gonna have
we're gonna have to cut it wit just
doesn't fit into the for the moment in
the film where it's supposed to belong
to I thought oh well never mind you know
a lot of chicken I eat and a lot of
other things and just a hell of a lot of
working out and that's gone but that's
fine that's that's how you roll when
you're doing movies and then somebody
said you know you've just been on Conan
and you've been half naked in the shower
scene yeah so watch that I was like
dammit dammit the man's just sort of
yeah throw me out there under the bus
but first of all we added some music
that I thought helped well at Brown took
a brown yeah yeah let's take a look it
was really fantastic
[Applause]
yeah yeah I don't know I mean mmm I feel
any makes you feel any better yeah
that's how I showers I carry slowly out
of context it love it it looks like
you're confused by water
either that I'm really drunk I'm about
right in the shops
[Laughter]